[Music]
president joe biden has proposed raising
the corporate income
tax rate from 21 to 28
the rate increase would raise more than
700 billion dollars in additional
revenue over the next decade
to help finance his american jobs plan a
higher corporate tax rate will help
finance new spending
but it will come at a cost a higher
corporate rate increases the incentive
to shift profits out of the united
states under biden's proposal the u.s
corporate tax rate
including state and local taxes would be
roughly 32 percent
and the highest among oecd nations this
will make it more attractive to locate
income in foreign jurisdictions
a higher corporate tax rate would also
make investing in the united states
more expensive a higher tax burden on
investment can lead to a smaller capital
stock
lower labor productivity and lower
economic output in the long run
to the extent that a corporate tax rate
reduces labor productivity
it will lead to lower wages for everyday
workers
how high do you think the corporate tax
rate should be
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei